so we've built this all off this
introductory term
that i gave you here i'm going to give
you one that is slightly
different i'm going to ask you to work
out
before we dive into our exercise this
oh make sure i go for turmeric yeah
there we go
we just looked at a log let's consider
an exponential okay in some ways this
will actually be easier
for us but you're still gonna have to do
integration by parts so what i would
encourage you to do
is to start with this is a generalized i
n term
you can actually do this just like we
just did three right
you can choose which is going to be u
which is going to be dv
and you're going to get a recurrence
relation out of it
once you've done that let's see if we
can work out
once you've got a recursive formula for
it something that looks like this
this is our recursive formula or our
recurrence relation here
let's see if we can use that to work out
what i3 is
okay so there's our two steps let me say
them one more time
we're going to try and work out what the
recurrence relation is it'll be i n
equals
and then there will be some stuff
that'll include an i n minus
one so it will refer to itself and then
what we're going to try and do is use
that that recurrence relation
to work out what i3 is i'll give you a
few minutes to have it play
and then i'll show you how i do it
here's where i'm going to pick up i'm
sort of going to do
what we did here with uh the log x
integral
but i'm going to do it in reverse right
where we ended up with
with our log x integral was we ended up
with this generalized term okay
but that was just because i was trying
to do this spoiler free because if at
the start i'd introduced it to the power
event you'd be like ah this is what
we're doing okay
but now now that we know we can have
this idea of a recurrence relation
there's nothing stopping us from
starting right at the top at
an arbitrary point on the ladder and
then use that to go further down so
let's just start with xn
x to the n e to the x okay what are the
appropriate choices for u
and db
thank you very much we'll choose this is
x to the power of n and we choose this
as e to the x because
because it's it's like i don't even have
to do anything to integrate this right
um i get e to the x there what do i get
from my d u term
and x to the n minus one fantastic and
by the way
that's one of the signs right there you
can be like oh great it's going to start
reducing
hence reduction formula that name okay
so that's a good sign
when we go ahead and do this right i'm
going to do my uv which you can see here
u v right
which by the way sorry excuse me
by the way looks kind of weird you're
like i integrate and then
huh like it's the same thing but this
this does happen right this is what
integration by parts
routinely hands us minus and then an
unnecessarily large integral sign here
comes by v
d u right it's going to be my e to the x
and then i'm going to get my n lots of x
to the n minus one
okay now have a look you've got to see
through it a little bit right
where is my recursive term hiding and
the answer is
if i pull this n out i pull the n out
then you get e to the x that's there and
you've got an
x to the n term except it's x to the
n minus one so let's go ahead and put
that together
i'm going to take that n out like i said
excuse me and then i get my
everything up here except it's one term
less
i n minus one are you okay with that
ta-da that wasn't so hard okay but i
said can we use that
to get to i three so now i've got a
particular value of n
that i'm after so i'm gonna say
therefore if this is i
n what's i three going to be equal to
i'm just gonna start subbing stuff in
right i'm gonna go here's my value of
and i see it coming up three times so
i'll do three substitutions
x cubed yeah
times e to the x minus what
three lots of i2 there's my n
minus one you're like what's i 2 i don't
know let's go again right because i have
a definition
for what i 2 is i just have to
substitute in 2. so i get x
cubed to the x that's just hanging out
the front minus 3 lots of
and then i once more with feeling okay
so i'm going to go
x squared e to the x
minus 2 lots of i
1. do i know what i one is yes now i
could work out
i won but just for the sake of it right
just see how far we can take this okay
if i go x cubed e to the x it's still
hanging out there 3
lots of x squared e to the x
if i then say hold on by the definition
of what
i n is if i just put in one let's just
see what happens
okay so it looks like i'm going to get
i'll use a curly bracing here
i'm putting in one now right x
to the power of 1 so that's done e to
the x
minus one lot
of i zero now you're like
i started off this idea going one two
three and counting up right i
i haven't yet thought about whether i
zero makes sense but does it look back
at where we began does does i zero
actually have a
sensible definition the answer is it
totally does
it's x to the power of zero which is one
it's
e to the x my favorite integral of all
time it's my favorite i did it already
once today
right so therefore i can say i've i've
climbed down to the bottom of the ladder
i can get off this thing now yeah
uh x cubed e to the x minus
three lots of and i am going to expand
out all these brackets in a moment
x squared e to the x minus 2 x e to the
x okay this thing here
is the integral of e to the x which is
e to the x tada and by the way this
should look familiar we've done this a
couple of times already before right
plus a constant i've finished all of my
integrations okay so at this point here
i'm just going to kind of think to see
do i have stuff that i can take out as a
common factor
it looks like an e to the x which
appears every single time so i'm going
to pull that out
and then carefully i'm just going to
look term by term i'm going to have to
do a couple expansions
simultaneously but i reckon we can
handle it i'm going to get an x x cubed
here
okay what comes next minus 3x minus 3x
squared
very good then here watch out there's a
minus 3
times a minus 2 times an x
so that gives you
plus 6x
then look again minus three times minus
two
times minus one i've already pulled out
the e to the x haven't i so what do i
get
i've got three negatives so i think i
get minus six okay with that
and then that's it plus your constant
hanging out there
how do you feel about that process is it
okay
um you can see you can build up from the
bottom like we've done here
or you can actually start from the top
from the generalized version
and then go from the top and then just
substitute in all these previous
versions until you get to something
where you're like i know what that
integral is
right and just as a note for us just
because it's kind of the first time
we've done it
maybe it'd be helpful for all of us to
just put down
explicitly what that i zero term is it's
the integral of
x to the zero e to the x just so that we
all remember why we get out this term
okay ta-da
recurrence relations sounds fancy many
things in extension too like integration
by parts or complex numbers they sound
fancy then they are
this is really like the combination of
calculus and stuff we did from
series and sequences like a series that
refers to itself